hi everyone welcome to another episode
of science and technology q a for kids
and others a reminder that i'm happy to
try to answer any questions you throw at
me about science
technology math other kinds of things
uh
whatever i know about i'm happy to talk
about
um
let's see we have a few questions saved
up here and i'm hoping we'll get uh more
coming in
so the question here from
bio
um
asking what's the difference between
astro particle physics
and astrophysics
which is more interesting in my opinion
all right let's talk about this
so
you know astronomy
is kind of this study of well literally
i guess in greek it would mean the the
lore of the stars so to speak
but um astronomy
tends to be
things like what stars are where in the
sky
what can you see through a telescope
those kinds of things
more kind of the what's out there in the
universe
astrophysics
is more about how do the stars actually
work what's the physics behind how the
stars work
not so much oh there's betelgeus there's
altair there's this star there's that
star but how does a red giant star work
how does a a white dwarf star work those
kinds of things generically about stars
not that particular name of a star
um you can talk about that a little bit
more detail astroparticle physics is a
quotes newer field seems newer to me
because i was involved with it right
when it was starting in the late 1970s
so it's not quite so new anymore but um
it has to do with
understanding the relationship between
particle physics the study of things
like electrons and quarks and those
kinds of things and the study of of
things on on an astronomical scale
and particularly
studying those kinds of things
in terms of what happened in the early
universe
let's talk a little bit about these
different pieces so astronomy
well
the
the question of sort of what stars are
there where
um
that's a question that
uh people have been interested in for a
long time you know there are some number
of hundreds of stars depending on where
you live and how bright the sky is there
are some number of hundreds of stars you
can see with the naked eye there are in
our galaxies there are about a hundred
billion stars there are about a hundred
billion galaxies in our universe
and uh the there's sort of a question of
where are all those things and people
people wonder a lot
questions like are the stars uniformly
distributed in the sky or are they
clumped up we know they're clumped into
galaxies even within galaxies there are
clumps of stars and there's sort of a
question
if if you are
on a particular star what is the
likelihood that there will be a star
within some number of light years of you
so for example for us we have the sun
that's our our friendly local star
and then the next nearest star is about
four light years away that means that it
takes light four years
to travel from that star to us
in the in the way that relativity works
if you're the photon of light
no time will have elapsed between the
time when you were omitted on that star
and the time when you received by us
that's because of time dilation uh at
the speed of light there's infinite time
dilation so as far as the photon is
concerned it was emitted and then it was
and then it was received by us but as
far as we're concerned uh as as sort of
things not traveling at the speed of
light
it would take us it would be a a
four-year journey even if we were going
at the speed of light to to reach the
nearest star
uh that was a bit confusing but the the
point i'm making is that as a
if if we look at when was the light
emitted and when was the light received
but we are stationary then we can say it
was emitted four years ago it's received
now
um if we were actually traveling at the
speed of light the story will be
different but in any case the the
nearest star other than the sun alpha
centauri a triple star that's uh about
4.3 light years away and then there's as
you look at other stars uh there's a
whole bunch of stars nearby i think the
next one is barnard star about six light
years away and you can just ask what's
the what's the chance to find a star uh
that is a certain distance away from
from the sun
actually we a lot of stars the sun is a
fairly big star and there are a lot of
fairly dim stars out there so even
stars that are quite close to us we may
not know that they're there yet
um because they're too dim to see
but this question about how many stars
are there at a certain distance away
from us uh is an interesting question
and there tends to be sort of a
universal law that is only partly
understood it's a power law that
determines uh sort of the the how many
stars you typically find a certain
distance away from a given star and and
the stars tend to be clumped as a result
of gravity they're clumped in a large
scale in in galaxies but they're even
clumped on a smaller scale um but that's
sort of the the subject of astronomy is
things like where are those stars and
how are the stars moving around and so
on not so much the physics of what
causes the clumping what causes the
motion and so on
a big sort of story of astrophysics is
things like how do stars work
and the stars go through this uh there's
a so-called main sequence stars of which
has sun as an example um there's a a
sequence of different stages that stars
go through i don't actually know what
the letters come from but it's oba
uh ob a f g
uh i forget what's r g is what is the
stage our sun is at
um and uh there's a what it's a question
of what um
how
what kind of nuclear reactions are
happening in the star and at some point
it will have used up all the fuel of a
certain kind all the kinds of atoms of a
certain kind will kind of to go on and
start using heavier atoms and so on and
that that determines the sort of
sequencing of stars but the whole theory
of how stars work
and uh you know how hot is it in the
middle of the sun maybe 10 million
degrees centigrade um those kinds of
things that's that's a big subject of
astrophysics
and a lot of other questions about how
stars form
um how
uh the the the application of physics
to
things that um about how astronomical
sized objects work
then sort of another big field is
cosmology
and cosmology is the story of kind of
how things work at the scale of the
whole universe
things like what was the universe like
when it was very young 14.6 billion
years ago it was a it was very small and
very hot that was the big bang
uh when the universe started expanding
uh as it has continued to expand up
until now
um and uh cosmology is kind of the study
of the very large-scale structure of the
universe
not uh really paying too much attention
to the individual galaxies individual
stars but just asking what's the
structure of the whole universe what's
the rate of expansion of the whole
universe what's the uh what
characteristics does the universe have
kind of a corner case of cosmology is
things about what happened in the very
early universe
and that's kind of a place where in a
sense the um
uh the the kind of the the questions of
astrophysics and cosmology and
astroparticle physics all in a sense
intersect
what happened in the very early universe
well
one thing we know for sure is the very
early universe was was small and hot
compared to our current universe
we
uh in fact probably the at the very very
beginning of the universe the universe
was sort of infinite infinitely small in
a sense infinitely hot
in our current theory of physics that
we've been working on recently uh
something very bizarre is the case about
the early universe
whereas in our current universe space
has three dimensions you know you could
move in in three distinct directions
we think that the very early universe
was probably infinite dimensional
and um as gradually as the universe kind
of expanded it became lower and lower
dimensional until eventually we get our
current three-dimensional experience of
of the universe
but
what happened in the very early universe
was that
lots of
right right now in the universe most of
the universe is hydrogen
protons and electrons uh making up
hydrogen atoms that's what most of the
universe is today
when the universe was hot enough
the protons and the electrons weren't
bound together in hydrogen atoms they
were free-floating like they would be in
fire they're in a plasma um and so there
were just these particles these protons
and electrons bouncing around um there
was a time about uh what was it about a
hundred thousand years after the
beginning of the universe
when things had cooled down to the point
where actual hydrogen atoms could form
that's an important moment in the
history of the universe because it's
when the universe became transparent to
light
before that time it was more like a
plasma like fire that you can't kind of
see through after that time it became
transparent and that means that light
that started at that time can still can
make it through the universe if it was
if it was emitted at a time when the
universe had become transparent the
light just keeps keeps moving if it was
emitted at a time before the universe
became transparent the light sort of
doesn't get out and it just uh it uh it
won't we won't it won't be directly
visible by us
but
so what happened in the in the earlier
and earlier universe things were hotter
and hotter
and that means there's more and more
energy the particles there have more and
more energy temperature is is
determines the kinetic energy
essentially the speed of of of particles
um running around
and uh at um
as we go back earlier and earlier in the
universe we get to the time when it was
a a billion degrees centigrade and a
trillion degrees centigrade and so on
okay so one
strange thing happens when things are
really really hot
which is that you start making particle
antiparticle pairs
so what happens is
in so electrons have a certain mass
positrons the anti-electrons have a
certain mass equal to the mass of the
electron
if you can sort of pump in enough energy
to make up the mass of an electron as a
and a positron
in the standard units of particle
physics it's about 1 mev 1 million
electron volts if you have that amount
of energy
then that energy can be converted into
the masses of an electron and a positron
and so what will happen is the electron
and positron will
uh
they'll you'll be able to produce those
two particles you might have a photon
with that amount of energy and the
photon can essentially split into an
electron or a positron this is sort of a
a fundamental thing in particle physics
and in quantum field theory this idea
that you can have a a particle um and
it
the the just like
okay so so when it comes to
uh something like electric forces
between particles charged particles have
electric forces between them those
electric forces are understood in
quantum field theory as due to the
exchange of photons so an electron is
going along and it emits a so-called
virtual photon which is absorbed by
another electron for example and the
momentum that's transferred by that
virtual photon is what kind of pushes
what causes one electron to be pushing
another electron so to exert a force so
to give you the kind of electrical force
between two electrons
it turns out that sort of same
phenomenon you can kind of turn it
around and say actually a photon just
coming along with enough energy can
produce and can
that that virtual photon can turn into
an electron positron pair
um and
the um
uh
let's see the the the basic phenomenon
that happens is when you have
essentially when you have enough energy
to make up the the masses of the
particles you will be able to turn
energy into particle antiparticle pairs
and so in the sufficiently early
universe when it was hotter and hotter
and hotter and hotter
um you can produce particle antiparticle
pairs of all kinds of particles
so first you're producing electron
positron pairs
then you might have i don't know maybe
proton antiproton pairs probably
wouldn't actually get those you'd get
instead quark antiquark pairs those are
the things inside protons
and you would get um oh i don't know
things like uh all the different sort of
zoo of particles higgs particles all
kinds of different kinds of things
produced in the early universe the early
universe is sort of a generator of the
complete zoo of possible particles and
that's why sort of particle physics it
meshes with uh that's one of the reasons
why particle physics it meshes with
astrophysics is because in the
sufficiently early universe you get sort
of the complete spectrum the complete
zoo of possible particles produced and
the effects of those particles and their
various kinds of interactions can have
an effect on on the structure of the
universe
another place where astropolitical
physics sort of
shows up
is in the question of there are sort of
mysteries in astrophysics
the kind of one of the bigger ones is
this question of dark matter
so the the universe has a certain amount
of mass in it that we can tell is there
because it's stars and we can see the
stars shine and we can kind of guess how
much mass there is because we know how
much mass how how much mass there is in
a star that shines with a certain
brightness and so on so we can estimate
how much mass there is in like a galaxy
for example
well then we can look at
how does the galaxy actually behave in
terms of its rotation and things like
that
how much mass does it behave as if it
has in it based on the force of gravity
that seems to be being exerted by one
part of the galaxy or other parts of the
galaxy and unfortunately there's a big
mismatch between those things it seems
like there's a lot more mass in galaxies
than mass that we can account for on the
basis of looking at stars based on their
brightness and so on and so that's led
to this idea of dark matter
where the notion is that there's
something there that isn't bright isn't
shining isn't like a star that we can
kind of uh see and measure so to speak
but it still has a gravitational effect
and so there's been sort of a big trace
on for the last i don't know 25 years or
more a little bit more than that perhaps
now
for what is that dark matter
and there's some weird cases where
they're for example are colliding
galaxies and you sort of see this this
place in the middle where you don't see
anything but it clearly has a
gravitational effect so the skill is
some kind of thing that is uh has
gravitational effect but it's not like a
star so what is it you know is it tiny
black holes is it some new kind of
particle nobody knows what it is and
there are a variety of candidates some
of them are just sort of individual
particles some of them are much bigger
objects like uh
things things like tiny black holes tiny
stars all kinds of which which are not
uh luminous and so on uh other kinds of
things so kind of the hunt is on for
what can dark matter be
and dark matter could be particles that
are
very much like the particles we already
know except just not particles that
interact very much they wouldn't have
electric charges things like that they
might be particles very different from
the ones we already know they might be
particles that are trillions of times
less massive than the ones we already
know that's something that actually our
theory of physics suggests might might
be going on
but so that's a place where people are
interested in trying to hunt for those
kinds of particles the particles must
interact very weakly with ordinary
matter and so they're all kinds of
elaborate experiments trying to detect
the presence of kind of very weakly
interacting particles that might be part
of this kind of dark matter thing and so
that's another sort of big piece of the
astroparticle physics story so if you
look at these different areas
you know in
astrophysics as such
some of the questions that have been
sort of long around there are things
like uh how do stars shine that's kind
of known how do stars form there's a
decent amount known about that how do
stars explode in supernovas there's
again a decent amount knowing about that
um
the many of the kind of most obvious
questions in astrophysics are somewhat
under control i would say at this point
but when it comes to these questions
about dark matter and so on which more
relates to particle physics there's sort
of a great big we don't know what's
going on type sign there and uh so
that's that's sort of a feature of that
field
let's see
um
all right let's see well we got another
question here
about
why do doctors say that no vaccination
can be a hundred percent effective okay
very different area of science
um
well gosh
um
well how do vaccines work how does the
immune system work
so
we are
continually getting bombarded by all
kinds of viruses and bacteria
and other things that
would
harm us if they started reproducing
inside us and so on
and so we have evolved we being mammals
humans etc have evolved a couple of big
mechanisms to kind of keep the intruders
out
and those two mechanisms are usually
called the innate immune system and the
adaptive immune system the innate immune
system also exists in lower animals the
adaptive immune system is kind of a
special for mammals and so on um the
the innate immune system
basically what it does
is
it it tries to figure out is there some
chemical feature essentially
of
um
the
the things that are likely to be
intruders that's different from
things that are likely to be part of us
and what tends to happen is that it
has
in in kind of uh you know in one's nose
and other places where sort of one's
continually ingesting stuff from the
outside there's kind of
cells
and a system that
are
intended to kind of
uh keep out the intruders by noticing
that they are intruders from various
kinds of chemical properties of those um
of those things and there are a variety
of chemical properties that are used i
think more get discovered every year of
different kinds of tricks
that the innate immune system uses to
try and recognize uh kind of that's
that's something that we want to keep
out and where it wants to
uh
kill off
that
cell kill off that bacterium whatever it
is to to keep it out of out of the
system
um and even once it is in
i'll see if i can remember how this
works
the um
uh
there are there are also yeah the innate
immune system also works i think
internally um in um
but again with this idea that it's a
sort of fixed set of fixed repertoire of
kind of um things that one knows are bad
it's kind of like in in computer
security if you have a firewall there
are certain patterns that you say if you
see a packet that looks like this it's
definitely bad just throw it out
so the more sophisticated immune system
is the adaptive immune system which is
intended to deal with
antigens that aren't necessarily of a
kind that one's ever seen before and a
way to kind of get those
to to notice and get rid of those
antigens
antigen means a a bad thing that is sort
of a foreign of a foreign thing from the
outside so the the big
feature
so the things one's interested in
dealing with
are
they're all
uh
things that are
that they're all biological things made
of proteins uh that have been specified
by
by um uh by dna and rna and so on but
they're all in the end it's protein
molecules and these protein molecules
are all different shapes and so on and
so sort of the the big idea of the
adaptive immune system is know the set
of shapes
of molecules that correspond pieces of
molecules that correspond to
things that are part of us
and recognize when it's a shape that
isn't a shape that is something that is
something that's part of you when it's a
foreign uh sort of alien shape then
recognize that and
and try and kill it off or get rid of it
so how does that how does that work
well
the main idea
is is the following it's called the
clonal selection theory of the immune
system and it seems to be what's
happening
what happens is
okay so that the whole thing is a little
complicated and i'm not sure i know all
the details of it i'm not sure all the
details are really known yet um but uh
the
in
well let's talk about one of the ways
that those shapes are recognized which
is with antibodies
antibodies are little tiny
fairly small
molecules
that whose job is to kind of paint
the bad stuff so antibodies try to
attach themselves to
to protein that is sort of uh
or cells that have kind of uh bad
protein associated with them that are
non they're not things that we think are
part of ourselves that kind of they're
kind of marking the things that are
are kind of a bad so
when i say marking them what happens is
these little pieces of antibody which
are little immunoglobulin molecules
again pieces of protein they attach
themselves to the surface of a cell that
is supposed to be a a bad cell and they
kind of mark that cell as bad and then
other parts of the immune system notice
that and come and and uh and kill that
cell
so the question is how does the antibody
know what to mark and what not to mark
so the idea is the following they're
about there are the the way they immune
their little y-shaped molecules
and those molecules that make up the the
antibodies they have
this these these many different possible
structures
they have they come from essentially
genetic sequences that cause them to be
able to make um a collection of
different possible
proteins are made from these sequences
of amino acids um 20 different possible
amino acids and and each protein is just
specified by some some different
sequence of essentially letters that
correspond to these different amino
acids
and so in
in antibodies there are there's a
there's a region of the antibody where
it has great diversity you can you can
just have any sequence of within within
certain constraints any sequence of
letters can be there and different
sequences of letters will make different
shapes
and so what happens is how many
different shapes can you make well in
our antibodies we can make about 100
billion different shapes and um
the
i
know maybe it's a more like 10 billion
different shapes
so
all the time
we are producing antibodies
with randomly
with
each antibody we produce
has one of these 10 billion different
possible shapes and all the time there
are there are billions of antibodies
circulating in our blood and they will
randomly have picked one shape or
another
okay so then what happens
well what happens is
that
when there is an antigen
where
one of those shapes fits onto the
antigen
then
the um
that antibody will bind to the antigen
and then a system
part of the immune system notices that
oh that antibody bound to something that
must be an antibody that matters
and the immune system will just start
producing more and more of that kind of
antibody that's what mounts an immune
response is the recognition and first of
all you're randomly picking antibodies
you're randomly generating antibodies
then every so often one of those
antibodies will stick onto something
when it sticks
then the immune system knows let's
amplify let's make more and more of that
particular kind of antibody not all the
other 10 billion antibodies but that
particular antibody just make more and
more of that antibody and that that kind
of is the is the mounting of the immune
response and then those antibodies will
start sort of painting the other cells
that are identified the other
antigen the other things that are
identified as bad and the
your t cells will come along and and
start um uh consuming those things and
and so on so that's that's sort of the
basic idea is you're randomly selecting
possible antibodies then the ones that
that turn out to stick are the ones that
get amplified and that is what generates
the immune response
now the big question is why do the
antibodies not start looking at random
cells in your body and say
hey that doesn't look like a good cell
i'm going to go attack that
well the reason they don't
is that the antibodies and the immune
system is kind of trained for each of us
early in our lives
to know what self and what's not self
and so there's a thing called the thymus
glands somewhere in one's in one's chest
that um is a place where
there is sort of training going on in
early life
of this is a this is a protein that is a
self protein and it's not something for
which you should mount an immune
response and generate antibodies and
anything that you see there is something
that you you kind of know
is
is something that is
part of your of you and so antibodies
ignore that thing and only if you see
something that isn't part of you
should you go and attack it and go
through this whole you know attach
yourself get other antibodies like you
made all those kinds of things
now
it doesn't always work perfectly and
that's what causes autoimmune diseases
is when you don't correctly identify
which um
which thing is a is a is a piece of self
and which thing is a foreign intruder so
to speak
i'm i'm simplifying a lot in in what i'm
describing i'm talking only about
antibodies there's a whole separate
system to do with t cells t cells are
complete white blood cells that have a
thing called the t cell receptor which
is something a little bit like the way
antibodies work except that the t cell
receptor will directly it will bind to a
cell and t cells will more directly be
the things responsible for killing cells
and so on antibodies are just painting
cells with so other t cells can come
along and um
and actually do the do the dirty work of
killing off the cell or killing off the
the bacterium or killing off the the the
cell that's inside us that's been
infected by it by virus
by the way there's always the question
how do you know if a cell has been
infected well there's another whole
mechanism biology is full of these
complicated mechanisms there's another
whole mechanism that essentially a cell
is continually exposing pieces of the
protein that's inside the cell that's
kind of a conveyor belt molecular
conveyor belt that's taking pieces of
that protein up to the cell surface so
that it exposes them on the cell surface
in a particular place on the cell
surface
um in in a particular structure on the
cell surface and many copies of it on
the surface of a particular cell and
that's kind of like exposing this is
what i'm like inside the cell says and
that allows the immune system to notice
whether that is a is a cell that has
good stuff inside or bad stuff inside so
that's and that's that's kind of how
when a virus infects a cell the virus is
is doing its work um in
inside the cell but what's happening is
the proteins it's making are getting
transported in pieces up to the cell
surface and getting recognized
there by by antibodies and t cells and
so on
okay so that's very rough indication of
how the immune system works so one
question would be
if you get sick with something
that means that you've got some foreign
protein some antigen that's come in
you've mounted this immune response
you've generated lots of antibodies for
that thing and that's all good you've
you've successfully you know you've
rebuffed the intruders you've you've
killed off all those cells that's great
you're better
now what
well the immune system has a memory if
you ever got sick it sort of remembers
what you got sick with and if it ever
sees that kind of antigen again
it's going to spring into action much
more quickly and be able to generate
antibodies more quickly of that
particular type
and uh or and be able to respond and
rebuff
the um the the disease even before it
starts to uh to sort of make you really
sick i mean what one thing to say is
when you
get a virus bacteria whatever you know
you'll typically be getting a very small
number
i don't know how many hundreds thousands
maybe millions of like virus particles
in your nose or something like this
but to actually make you sick
that it requires many more copies of the
virus and so what will happen to
actually make you so clinically visibly
sick it'll require many more copies of
the virus
and what happens is viruses they infect
cells they cause the cell to generate
more virus the cell eventually explodes
it spews virus all over the place little
pieces of virus that little viruses that
get spread out and they go infect other
cells and so on and that process
takes
over the course of i don't know days or
whatever or a day um that uh
you're you're making more and more cells
be infected by the virus
and what's happening is uh that that's
there's often a sort of doubling every
so often of the number of infected cells
and the question is the immune system is
coming in and it's trying to attack
what's happening
um if the immune system if the amount of
if the immune system is kind of on alert
as that doubling starts to happen the
immune system will swing into action
aggressively enough that it will
basically cut off that doubling and you
won't get sick it won't get to the sort
of runaway doubling that um
that generates enough virus or whatever
to make you clinically sick
um but if the immune system is kind of
not on alert it will typically it will
often or might i wouldn't say typically
because i don't think we really know um
it will it might take it it will tend to
take it
uh too long to respond and so it will
already there will already be too much
virus in you and it'll then be a much
more difficult fight for the immune
system to ramp up and start start um
knocking out the virus and so on
so the question is what causes the
immune system to have sort of the memory
of what it should be on alert to
and this is where things get a bit
complicated because a lot is not really
known about this
people
they're a type of white blood cell
called b cells
and there are things called memory b
cells that people talk about which are
supposed to be kind of versions of b
cells that were b cells by the way what
what produce antibodies and different
sort of when you are
a
the the details of a b cell will
determine what kinds of antibodies it
can produce
so if you have a b cell of that that
clone that um
that particular type of b cell and you
have
lots of that particular type of b cell
you'll be well enabled to produce that
particular kind of antibody to attack
that particular kind of antigen
but so a typical kind of theory is
that there are memory b cells there are
b cells that kind of remember
what antibodies they produce and that
over the course of if we won't get sick
with something one of the theories has
been that you've got memory b cells that
kind of hang around with the knowledge
of of uh how to generate antibodies to
the thing you got sick with and they
hang around forever so the theory goes
and if ever they're called into action
uh 10 years later whenever whenever it
is
those b cells will spring into action
and be able to produce antibodies
this theory is not completely convincing
i think because the the uh
experiments to find these things i don't
think are very convincing um this that's
my my impression and also
the the typical lifetime of a white
blood cell is like a month or so
and so what one would be claiming if one
said oh there are these b cells and they
last forever
it's like well most of these cells only
last a month but there are some that
might last your whole life
and that seems rather implausible i
think generally one one has much better
guess
that
that what's happening is more something
where there is one of these b cells and
then somehow it passes itself its
information on to another b cell and
keeps going from there and so on and
there are mechanisms that could happen
through sort of linear lineages of cells
there's a different theory actually that
was
come up with i guess in the 1970s
um
that was the so-called network theory of
the immune system actually invented by
the chap who invented monoclonal
antibodies which are an
important therapeutic tool
the thing that's for example used for
sort of early treatment of of covad is a
monoclonal antibody monoclonal
antibodies are just
a
uh molecular antibodies it's a method
for producing just tons and tons of
antibodies of a specific type
actually it makes use of a cell that
would would sometimes if used in the
wrong way would be something which would
produce kind of a blood cancer but it's
kind of hijacking the mechanism of that
cell that would usually just produce
more and more and more cells hijacking
it and using it to produce lots and lots
of antibodies and that's that's a a
therapeutic method anyway the chap who
invented that that method um
also came up with this some
theory of how the immune system works
which was some
uh which is a little different from this
idea of their memory b cells and they
last forever
more it's a theory that you produce
antibodies
and you're producing antibodies and then
gradually
as you just produce more and more
antibodies once an antigen has showed up
but in order to stop you producing
antibodies the antibodies themselves
become essentially antigen and so then
you end up producing anti antibodies
that are antibodies that attack
antibodies so to speak and then what
happens is there's this whole kind of
dynamic equilibrium between antibodies
and anti-antibodies and
anti-anti-antibodies
and so on and so there's this whole sort
of process of keeping the immune system
in kind of dynamic equilibrium through
having antibodies and anti-antibodies
and so on i believe that recently
actually somebody found uh
usually the the first level antibodies
called ab1 antibodies the second level
called ab2 antibodies i think somebody
found an ab2 antibody for covid for
example which means that there are
anti-antibodies being produced
which is kind of what this theory
suggests should be there
but
in any case the the in that theory
what's happening is instead of having a
particular cell that is sort of hanging
around and able to sort of spring into
action and produce
uh kind of um
or produce the antibodies you need
instead you have this kind of this whole
cascade of different kinds of cells that
are all kind of dynamically the
antibodies is causing one to have
anti-antibodies the anti-antibodies are
then causing one to make antibodies
again and etc etc etc it's a sort of
dynamic collection of things it's kind
of analogous to
you know when when you wonder how you
remember things
one possibility is and some of this
happens you know you have a memory
that was formed and sort of imprinted on
some synapse in your brain
50 years ago
and that same synapse is still there
but the other possibility is that you
you recall that memory and then you
remember the recalling of the memory
rather than that you have that memory
imprinted from the original time you
received the memory and that's kind of a
you know this sort of cascade version of
how you remember something is probably a
little bit more like how the immune
system works with this kind of dynamic
sequence of remembering things
so then the question is
uh what does the immune system um
uh how how does you know that that that
whole mechanism of the immune system
is um
uh is something that
has all kinds of features i mean one
question is for example
when you have let's say a virus
that has a particular genome sequence
it's going to produce a particular
protein
and that particular virus is going to be
one to which you mount antibodies and so
on
but then maybe the virus evolves
slightly maybe it has a few changes to
its genome that's happened with covid
for example all these various variants
of covid are various changes i mean some
of them covet is a is a virus with about
some
uh
29 000 base pairs that's the length of
its genome and most of these variants
have been like i don't know 10 15 base
pair changes out of that 29 000 i think
this uh omicron variant is like 31 base
pair changes it's kind of mysterious how
it got to be so many i think that's a
it's an interesting scientific mystery
right now but anyway it is a it is a
slightly more distant variant
but once the question then is you've got
your immune system it remembers
the antibodies it was producing to the
original virus
and the question then is when a variant
comes in how much can it rem can it
mount a good antibody response to that
variant
and
of course if you're only changing you
know 10 30 base pairs out of 29 000 that
means lots of the proteins that have
produced lots of the protein that's
produced by that virus hasn't actually
changed and so if you mounted a
successful immune response to the
protein so the first time around it's
pro it might be just the same protein
second time around no problem if it's
different
the um
uh
the thing that um uh that can be more
problematic and you there's the question
of you know do you manage to make
antibodies that are close enough what is
close enough mean well it probably means
something about the shape of the
molecule is the molecule shaped close
enough that it kind of fits in and
combined to the to the place it's
supposed to bind i think with the with a
covered virus there's this spike protein
which is a particular protein produced
by that virus
that is um the the the kind of the focus
of both
uh kind of a lot of the immune response
and um it's also
a lot of the variation between these
variants is concentrated in that area of
the virus i believe so it isn't really
the case but it sort of randomly spread
through the 29 000 base pairs but any
case the the question is you've got your
immune system and it's going to mount an
antibody response and does it mount an
antibody response as successfully to the
changed if it mounted if it got the
antibodies if it understands what to do
for the original virus can it understand
what to do for a variant virus
and the answer is well it seems to be
able to do okay much of the time but the
mechanisms
it's it's all
well so one possibility is that in this
if it is the case that the immune system
works by this kind of cascade of
producing antibodies anti-antibodies and
so on every time you go to another level
of that cascade you're kind of expanding
the region of of sort of potential
antibodies that you're making because
there's some errors in the way that that
sort of recognition and sequencing
happens
and so you're you're ending up getting
not just the precise same antibodies but
sort of a range of antibodies that are a
little bit more distant from the
original one now if that if the if the
thing gets too dilute you just won't
have enough antibodies to mount a good
immune response to a particular new
antigen but on the other hand if you if
that sort of ball of antibodies and i
say ball not in a physical sense
you can think of these different
possible antibodies as being sort of
arranged in a kind of shaped space
so you can just say i'm going to uh i'm
going to use i if you're using modern
machine learning it might actually do it
in you know be able to sort of give you
the the analog of that in a sort of
feature space of saying there's there's
proteins that are this shape over in
this corner ones that are this shape
over in this corner there's ones that
sort of intermediate shape between those
two things you can kind of lay out all
the possible shapes of antibodies in
this kind of shape space and so what
you're then asking for is things like uh
how far away how far did you move in
shape space between one variant of the
one variant of the virus and another
variant of the virus and how far did the
antibodies that you're producing kind of
how how big a region in shape space to
those antibodies cover
and so i think it's quite possibly the
case that over the course of i don't
know months whatever it is
that that uh if if it's true that
there's this sort of cascade of
antibodies and anti-antibodies and so on
that you're gradually making a slightly
bigger ball
of um of kind of uh of a range of types
of antibodies that you're making again
if it gets too dilute it's not going to
work well because then there just won't
be enough antibodies to to uh mount that
strong response to a particular antigen
but on the other hand if your ball of of
in shape space is too small and some new
antigen that might be a variant virus
comes in and it's too far away from that
ball it still won't do you any good
because you won't have any antibodies
that are good matches for the thing that
came in
so okay well having having described all
those things one can talk about things
about vaccines for example i mean
vaccines are
i'm kind of leaving out tons of tons of
stuff about how the immune system works
and and how um
uh lymph nodes work and and sort of the
exposure of of antigen to um
of of the of of actual immune system
cells to antigen and things like this
but but we're leaving that out but but
so roughly sort of the traditional
approach to vaccines has been
that
you
kind of provide something that is like
the antigen that you want the immune
system to produce antibodies
and you then you kind of expose the
immune system to that and you say look
here's a piece of antigen uh go attack
it make things to attack it
and
that's um
that's been something that um uh in the
but the problem is that you don't
actually want to get sick you don't want
to have enough antigen that you get sick
but somehow you want to expose the
immune system to the we want to get the
immune system so excited about that
antigen that it's going to generate tons
of antibodies to it even though you
don't have all that much antigen and so
the traditional approach to vaccines has
been to use these substances called
adjuvants
which are basically things that and
there are a variety of different ones
and that they're sort of peculiar things
that have been discovered over the years
to work well for this that just sort of
tell the immune system hey there's
something important going on here even
though there's not a lot of antigen just
parade all these immune system cells
past that small amount of antigen so
that you pay attention to that antigen
and generate a serious immune response
to the to the antigen and so when people
have had problems with with vaccines
traditional vaccines they've tended to
be more often associated with the
adjuvant substances than to the actual
vaccine itself and but those are the
things that are like telling the immune
system you know pay attention and
actually generate lots of antibodies to
this
so
in the case of covid the um
uh the amazing thing that was done was
to produce a vaccine in like
one-fifth or one-tenth the time that
anybody had ever produced a vaccine
before
and the way that was done was using a
new technology that's that's different
from the technologies that had been used
in the past
and the the the primary idea well the
the
couple of different ideas but but the um
um the mrna vaccines
their idea is
just
let's just essentially copy a little
piece of what the virus is doing not the
whole virus we don't want to copy the
whole virus because then we'd have virus
and that would be bad but we'll just
copy a piece of the virus like we'll
copy the spike protein piece of the
virus it's not a complete virus that
would be able to replicate and infect
things and so on it's just a piece of
virus and what we want to do
is to get it so that that sort of the
the rna code from that piece of the
virus is being put into cells in us
where it will be well it will produce
protein and that protein will show up
and be protein that's exposed on the
cell surface and so on and to which the
immune system will mount an immune
response
and
then and generate antibodies and so on
just the way and it will it will somehow
generate enough of those antibodies that
we will be able to uh if exposed to the
actual antigen we will be able to mount
a good immune response
and so the the particular way that these
things work is using this again very
impressive piece of technology these
lipid nanoparticles which are sort of
like versions of of of cells in
organisms except they're just
nanoparticles they're little little
things made of lipids um uh um
you know little tiny
long molecules uh
kind of um rod shaped molecules that are
arranged in this kind of um that make
something like an artificial cell an
absolutely microscopic artificial cell
and that's used to enclose
the rna that is um
is actually going to be the thing that
is going to specify that the proteins
you want to make and the idea is to get
those into
enough cells in one's body and have them
start producing the um uh the kind of
the
you know the piece of the virus that
will then be the thing that your immune
system will respond to and then your
immune system will come and and produce
antibodies uh probably produce t cell
receptor t cells with the right t cell
receptors to be able to mount an immune
response
now the question of how all this really
works and how long you know how how much
uh the that
that particular
uh
you know how how well some particular
variant will be covered by this or that
that's very difficult to figure out
and generally in medicine the one
feature of medicine tends to be
people don't make too many theories they
just say let's do the experiment let's
do some trial let's do a clinical trial
where we get uh one group of people who
have this thing one group of people who
don't have this thing compare the
outcomes and so on and just do sort of
empirical science
just see what happens because uh well
there has been a certain amount of bad
experience in the past
um
of sort of we've got a theory about how
things will work because often actual
medicine and actual biology is just more
complicated than people can possibly
imagine and so all these theories that
say it should work like this there's
this particular you know feature that
should work like this well actually
there are all kinds of details that show
up and maybe there's a detail that shows
up for one type of person or not another
type of person and so on and in the end
it seemed like the only kind of reliable
way of figuring out what to do is to do
experiments now sometimes like in the
situation with the pandemic it's tough
to do some of those experiments partly
because the time scales are short
you know there's ethical issues about
doing some of the experiments
and uh but particularly time scales are
short and so you can't do this you know
this traditional thing of you know take
five or ten years to
roll out vaccines and see what effects
they have and and then do do you know do
more iterations and so on there hasn't
been time to do that and so there's a
little bit more tendency to to you know
come one figure out what's going to
happen i think
what's tended to be the case is that
people have believed that it's just
impossible to have a theory so don't
even try to have a theory um and i think
that's sort of a pity because i think
that there's probably actually is a
theory to be had and i think that um in
uh
i've been interested in this myself of
of whether it's possible to use even
some some
techniques from
that have come out of our physics
project recently to be able to to
understand and model things that might
be happening in the immune system to
give on more of an intuition for what
might be going on you know what is
really happening in this shape space how
how is the effect over time of of sort
of the immune response being uh
affected by the passage of time and and
you know how is the immune response
decaying how is it how is it actually
just dying off or is it is it broadening
and so on what happens if you uh use
vaccines that are that have a particular
um
uh that that have a particular protein
have a particular sequence associated
with them and you keep kind of saying
generate more immune response to this
particular kind of sequence how what
effects does that have does that have a
good effect a bad effect
on
what's happening with uh
with the ability to respond to for
example variant viruses and so on and so
there are lots of interesting questions
there that uh i think one doesn't really
know the answer to and um it's uh um
it's something where i i kind of suspect
that a better theory of immunology would
make it much easier to reason about
what's actually possible and what's not
possible and what's what's a plausible
effect and not a plausible effect i mean
again i i say that that um uh you know
theories in medicine and biology are
always challenging because the thing is
more complicated than you can imagine
but that's kind of a a beginning to this
i think um i think the original question
here was was why
why are vaccines not 100 effective you
know
the the um
uh
there are so many different reasons i
mean in in um
uh
from sort of did you know if you got a
huge load of virus it may be so much
that it overwhelms the sort of even your
immune system that's at the ready
or
if you got if there was a a variant
that you know it can have a different
effect or or if the um uh the the immune
response that you mounted in response to
a vaccine wasn't as large as one might
have thought it would be for one reason
or another um that's another reason why
you might not mount an adequate immune
response
it's also the case that that the precise
details of what matters in the immune
response what actual piece of the immune
system is the most effective at killing
off a particular antigen particularly is
it a part of the the um the the antibody
system the b cells or the t cells um
these are these have different kinds of
characteristics i have to say before
this whole pandemic you know i was
pretty decently aware of the whole
antibody system i was not very aware of
the direct t cell uh immunity that the
fact that you can have kind of uh t
cells with particular t cell receptors i
think there are even more
possible t cell receptors maybe a
trillion different possible
configurations of t cell receptors than
there are antibodies but i was much less
aware of the the t cell response system
um then
and so that's that's um and you know it
occupies a much smaller section of the
immunology textbooks but that may
actually be the important part when it
comes to uh things like coronaviruses
and so on i don't think that's really
known for sure
um so that's that's a a small um
uh
uh
a little bit of of um about um
immunology i'm happy to try and answer
more questions about that
um
the uh
let's see
um
well see i think i might have time for
a couple more things here
um
uh there's a question from david here
quoting wikipedia that some bowhead
whales are estimated between uh to be
between 135 170 years old is this
estimate correct can mammals live to be
200 years old
well i don't know the specifics of this
uh i think whales have the feature that
they sort of
they grow a bit every season somehow and
anything
that sort of grows every season you can
typically tell how old it is by just
looking at how many growth spurts it's
had i mean like for a tree for example
there is a tree ring produced every
growing season and that's
you know when you when you sort of cut
down the tree you can see that that
cross section of tree rings and you can
just count the tree rings and that
basically tells you how many years old
the tree is i vaguely remember that
there's a similar mechanism for whales
so there may be maybe a good way to know
after at least after the whales died um
how old the whale had been
this question about how long organisms
live
oh interesting question i mean there are
organisms that live
uh from you know a day
to thousands of years
um
you know there are trees for example uh
uh redwood trees and things that are
like thousand years old more or more
than that there are um and there are uh
there are organisms that uh well live
shorter and longer amounts of time
tends to be the larger organisms tend to
live longer i guess it takes them a
while to grow to that size among other
things um organisms that are
very tiny um uh
tend to have kind of faster everything
goes faster metabolism goes faster they
live less time and so on
there's a good question why did
organisms live the time they live
what actually
limits the lifespan of organisms the
answer is nobody really completely knows
and
it could be if if you look at the sort
of long view of evolution
evolution has gradually tweaked
the way we are way biological organisms
are
and what tends to happen is the
organisms that are more successful there
are more of them they have more children
and those and so there are more and
so then the traits that are associated
with those organisms become the
prevalent traits that become the most
common traits
and that's the darwin's theory of
evolution by natural selection
is that the things that are naturally
the things where the organism is more
successful can have more children
those are the things that become the
dominant traits because those are the
things for which they're just more
organisms with those particular traits
that are produced
so a question is
is
living a certain amount of time
is it good for the species to live only
a certain amount of time you know if it
was the case that you had a species and
uh its members just lived for a really
really really long time
uh you might say well i don't know maybe
that wouldn't be such a good idea
because you've got all these all these
eager young organisms they're coming out
but there's no food for them because all
the food's been been being eaten by
these organisms that are a thousand
years old that are kind of old and
crotchety and not doing anything very
useful anymore and there's no food left
for the youngans who are the really
energetic ones who are going to produce
even more
uh organisms in the next generation so
in a sense then evolution
natural selection if there's a version
of the species where the oldens stay
around and a version of the species
where the old ones don't stay around the
ones the case where the old ones don't
stay around may be more successful and
so it may be by natural selection that
may be the dominant form of the species
so it could be that pure evolution has
caused it to be the case that species
don't live uh that don't live that long
and determined how long the species live
now you can still ask okay
so species have a um
a certain you know expiration date they
have a certain time that they're
supposed to live for
and it could be the case that you can
still say well okay
that was the official exploration time
but uh we're going to find some way to
to kind of uh circumvent
that expiration time and you know find
some medical intervention or whatever
that will let the whale or the human or
whatever live much longer than their
evolutionarily uh determined exploration
time might be now of course the next
question is what is the mechanism even
if evolution was determining the
expiration time how does it actually do
it
you know what what is it that that kind
of happens over the course of whatever
it is for humans you know 80 100 years
whatever it is um what what happens to
to cause that sort of uh uh
you know to cause the degradation that
eventually causes the organism to die
and
the answer is people don't completely
know there are various effects that go
on
um
there are uh a few where
there's well there are things that that
happen in the every time you
as you
you make new copies of cells you the the
cells you have i don't know your skin
cells turn over very rapidly um other
cells in your body turn over less
rapidly but gradually over time every
cell in your body has been replaced by a
a new youthful version of that cell
and every time that replication happens
it requires sort of re-reading your dna
and every time you read it there are
some changes to the dna particularly the
ends of the dna the telomeres at the
ends of the dna tend to get a little bit
shorter they usually start off with
maybe 50 telomeres at each end and maybe
every time you read it it gets shorter
by one maybe
there are also enzymes that will uh
uh chemicals that will add telomeres to
the end so it's not quite correct to say
every time it's copied there's there's
one less
but so one thing that might happen as
you age is you're having to produce more
and more and more copies of cells and
every time you make a copy it's slightly
degraded it could be slightly degraded
because of this telomeres it could be
slightly degraded because of errors in
the dna replication um and that would be
one reason why gradually over time the
errors would build up and something a
bit like that is probably happening with
with the generation of cancer and so on
is some
sort of the replication errors build up
and eventually they go off into a place
where where the cells start behaving in
very much the wrong way so that's one
possible mechanism is genetic damage
another possible mechanism is some
oxidative stress and oxidative damage um
and that's that's just sort of a general
i i
quite almost quite literally burning up
of components of cells that cause them
to be
uh kind of less
um less flexible and less
and less effective than they were before
um and
they're various of these molecular scale
mechanisms that seem to exist for aging
but nobody really knows exactly what the
uh
what the most significant are and so on
and people are always coming up with um
you know eat more of this
uh do less of that
um you know this will
slow down the aging clock i mean
unfortunately some of the things that
people say like like one that was quite
popular for a while was just eat less
you know have a caloric restriction just
eat fewer calories
um i think the you can end up with a
situation where yes it slows down the
aging clock but it slows down the whole
clock as well so it's kind of like i'm
going very very slowly and yeah you know
the the um uh you know in in
you might live longer but you'll live
slower so to speak as well so that's not
necessarily a win
but so
the question of of what um
what mechanisms there are
and and what even the the the absolute
upper limits
to um uh are
to uh to lifespans is really not known
and my guess is that eventually it will
be figured out how to essentially get
see see the thing is
every time we get to a new generation
every time we you know the we that the
children get made so to speak the
children start from from zero again and
they successfully make all those
wonderful nice youthful cells that old
old fogies like me don't have any more
so to speak and so clearly there is a
mechanism to take cells that sort of
come from me
and
make them kind of youthful again because
that's what happens in the next
generation and the question is can one
sort of plug into that
to to sort of uh extend a single
organism's kind of lifespan for example
and one doesn't know the answer to that
yet i mean there's as
if you look at the practicalities of for
example for humans
the um in places like the us mostly the
the life expectancy the the the the
typical
number of years that somebody will live
uh starting from when if they're alive
when they're born if you look when
they're born you say what's the average
number of years the person will will
live maybe it's 81 years i don't know
what it is or something in the u.s now
um but that that number has been going
up about a third of a year per year for
quite a long time
mostly as a result of specific
uh things avoiding specific kinds of
diseases most commonly heart diseases um
in the in what's happened over the last
few decades or so
um but but gradually you know there are
all kinds of different things that go
wrong
and one of the things is can you knock
off okay you understand how to avoid
this kind of thing going wrong we
understand how to avoid this kind of
thing going wrong um eventually more and
more and more things go wrong but if you
can if you can kind of knock off the big
ones then you extend that life
expectancy um but how far that will go
is is um uh is not clear i mean the
longest people have been no one delivers
125 years
um and uh
that um uh
and that but i'm sure that that will um
um in increase
um
over time although and you know it's
always a question of of um
how much
how much will be biology and how much
will be technology how much of it will
be sort of fix yourself and how much of
it will be
there's a thing that is
a really good replacement for
such and such an organ or whatever else
that is a technological thing that keeps
the whole system running well
but isn't the biological version of that
particular system
um
oh there was a question here about
vaccines um
what's different in the vaccines like
what's the difference between one
another
uh i could tell you what i know about
that which is somewhat incomplete i mean
there are three main vaccines in the u.s
uh fisa moderna and johnson johnson the
pfizer moderna vaccines are mrna
messenger rna vaccines
and that was kind of the mechanism i was
describing
where
um and the the um the johnson johnson
vaccine is is based on an adenovirus
um
the um
okay the mrna vaccines that they all
work
by basically producing
little pieces of virus proteins
in your cells
so that your cells will sort of expose
that virus protein and cause you to
mount a kind of practice immune response
and um the mrna ones the way they work
is these lipid nanoparticles
um
are physical things that have rna inside
them and they are small enough to kind
of slide into
your cells they get into the cytosol the
material that's inside the main part of
the cell
and they start they just they
usually when your cell produces proteins
there will be dna replication in the
nucleus of the cell there will be um and
then there will be messenger rna that
goes out
and starts getting red and producing
proteins in the main part of the cell
and what's what's happening with these
viru with these vaccines
is they are inserting lipid
nanoparticles into the main part of the
cell
and those lipid nanoparticles break open
they expose the rna then your standard
cell protein manufacturing apparatus
ribosomes and so on start up and they
say oh there's a piece of rna here let
me transcribe this piece of rna and turn
it into protein and that's what they do
they don't at that point they don't know
that that thing is not a piece of rna
that actually came from the cell nucleus
they're just like uh you know i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna replicate this
piece of rna
and um the uh
the thing that um
uh and that's that's the same way the
virus works i mean a virus has exposed
its rna there and the apparatus of your
cell will just start to um uh to
replicate it so it's kind of it's kind
of being like a a fake virus except that
it isn't a whole virus so it can't
actually do the whole
full replication of virus make more
virus type thing it's just whatever rna
got into that particular cell it will be
transcribed in that particular cell it
might be transcribed many times in that
particular cell but it's just in that
particular cell it's exposed on the cell
surface it's attacked by the immune
system i think that particular cell will
end up getting killed off it's kind of
the um uh it's the it's the it's the
sacrificial cell or something because it
was exposing this this essentially
antigen on its surface which causes an
immune response
now i mean that's all good
uh you know bad things can happen if the
lipid nanoparticle winds up in a cell
that if it starts some cascade where you
start getting some kind of
you know
more like an autoimmune response and so
on it's not really understood whether
that happens how much that happens
whether it happens in different organs
and so on it might be the case that if
the lipid nanoparticle gets into a
particular organ it will have a
different behavior than if it's in just
sitting in muscle tissue in your arm or
whatever those are those are complicated
issues that that um uh
there's uh uh
there's
sort of scattered medical data about at
this point but anyway that that's how
those vaccines the the pfizer and
madonna vaccines work that way and the
differences between those vaccines i
think is that they've picked slightly
different sequences um slightly
different parts of the um of the virus
rna sequence
to to produce protein for
um to be the thing that will be the sort
of the recognition thing that will be
used to um to respond to the uh to the
to to produce an immune response
and i think that's um
when the trials of of um these vaccines
were done they tried out a bunch of
different parts of the of the rna
sequence to figure out what was the most
effective part of the sequence to expose
and some some parts of the sequence
didn't have much of an effect some had
some weird bad effects and the ones that
were picked were the ones that seemed to
have the best effect
now the johnson johnson vaccine i think
works a different way
it is um
it pitches a ride on a dinovirus which
is a a type of virus that can infect
cells
and
that virus i believe goes into the cell
nucleus
and it starts um but it has on it it's
been kind of a a variant of that virus
the virus itself is is harmless
but it has a sort of piggybacking on it
is a piece of viral rna from the actual
covert virus
it can't be
that it can't end up becoming a viral
replication thing it's just goes into
the cell once so to speak and then it
again has this mechanism that
rna is produced that causes proteins to
start getting generated inside the cells
that get exposed that then have an
immune response and so on and that's
that's the that's the mechanism so far
as so far as i know and i think that's
that's been the the very clever thing
that's been done
for
uh
traditional vaccines as i say require
well they require lots of trial and
error of different adjuvants and
different pieces of protein and so on
and so on uh these have been able to be
deployed as quickly as they have because
of these new technologies i mean the
lipid nanoparticle technology and rna
vaccine
mrna vaccine technology was actually
developed primarily as a way to deal
with cancer to be able to make a kind of
custom vaccine that would be a vaccine
that would get your immune system to go
attack a particular cancer that you
might happen to have and no doubt the
the use of all this in uh in this um
uh
uh in this pandemic uh will mean that
there's great advances that can be made
in that kind of immunotherapy for for
cancer i mean it's also a question which
is uh one that i think people have been
interested in is could there be a
generic vaccine against uh all kinds of
uh you know common cold and this and
that and the other could there be some
sort of more generic approach and these
mrna vaccines are
they were actually being developed
before this pandemic came along as a
possible sort of more generic platform
for making uh sort of rapid deployment
uh vaccines for lots of different
viruses
okay well i think i'm being told that
i've run out of time here but i see um
uh
all sorts of um
oh boy all sorts of interesting
questions um
the uh
um
well that means we've got good things to
talk about um
uh
next week
um
all right well thanks thanks for all
those questions and um i think we should
wrap up for now
so uh bye for now and uh i'll be back